Dad, I need to rest.
He complains of chronic fatigue.
You did not notice those signs?
Whatever his condition, he's not fine.
You're having an increasingly difficult time hanging on to clients.
Should I be worried?
No, I want the job bad.
This is when you show up.
What do we need to do to turn this around?
Cancer is not a negotiation, Mr. Jensen.
I haven't heard from you in a while.
Everything alright?
Yeah, family issues.
I'll figure it out.
Want to talk about it?
Maybe I can help.
We're your family, Dane.
You're gonna wish you had this time back.
My dad's coming.
I asked him if we could go somewhere.
Are you closing a deal without me?
He is the only one that makes me feel safe.
Every family has its issues but you only have one family.
You don't want the job, is that it?
Everything I need, I already have.